i got your mama i know got you didn't
put me in the room nurse at home okay
i'm not gonna put you a nerf no put you
in my basement
[Music]
hi my name is gwen and that's my
daughter jade and i'm gonna teach her
how to make sweet potato pie i'm really
hoping that that it comes out good
i don't really know how to cook so first
you have to get the crust we already
have a pie crust here and you're going
to make sure that it's firmly inside of
the pan so why don't you try it i just
put my fingers in the corners you know i
don't cook girl teach me put your hand
in and you're going to help form it to
the pan is this hole okay those who are
ocd cover up the holes cover up your
holes cover up your holes
i don't mean to say that that doesn't
sound nice pie crust is done we're ready
for the filling
recipe was designed because one day i
bought too many sweet potatoes for
thanksgiving
and i had to get rid of them so i made
pie
and the kids loved it and everybody else
did too
so that was the history that was history
after that it's like what do you mean
for thanksgiving what do i want you know
what i want stop asking me what i want i
want to get it all blended nicely and so
it's nice and creamy look at this
mixture if it's smooth we got to be
honest look at this mixture mine's gonna
be way better so just be ready i've
eaten this recipe about
how many thanksgivings
i'm 25.
see how there's like little lumps of all
that dry stuff in your wet stuff
hmm
i was gonna do that you just why are you
so concerned with having on this side of
the table all right
your paw's on that side hello all right
what would i'm mary tell you right now
give me the spoon you're right you're
hurting it and that's why i stayed out
the kitchen for all of my life you want
to make sure you're having the lumps oh
now you're saying not to do it so you
can get in it get yeah get in there
uh-huh now you're saying we gotta pour
pour this into the pie yes like this is
gonna come out like the good good if you
would would yeah i told you don't teach
me how to cook i'll kick you out the
kitchen oh don't do that so now i'm
gonna make my crust the sugar is going
to act like a molasses isn't it yeah
girl you're learning something
i told you i wasn't cooking but i was in
the kitchen he was paying attention
okay so i'm just going to take my
crumble and i'm going to spread it
along the top
yeah you know like i like what you did
it looks real cute it's gonna be very
tasty it's cute but i'm gonna show you
how you're supposed to do this right
here so you just bumped my pie out of
the way i just gotta let the people see
what's going on you know what i mean so
what i'm gonna do we're gonna throw
some marshmallows
don't be all anal like she was like i
gotta put it in the middle yeah
don't do all that like that's true but
don't you want it to be nice and fluffy
i didn't put enough girl i even put the
first layer so let me oh there's layers
to this this layers to this i want to
help you i want to you can have it i
think it's cute i think it's oh so yeah
you like it i like it i think it's cute
because it's going to have a nice little
crust on top
look at that look at that use the whole
bowl let's put them in the oven let's do
it all right look at that oh
what you got over there what you got i
don't know what i'm trying to say
you know i'm very impressed with that's
the first time you've seen this i know i
am i like the the toastiness of the
marshmallows but what you think about
mine i mean i like the brown sugar
that's the only thing i can see so
that's the only thing i like so it's
kind of looking lit over here you know i
mean oh look at that it sounds very nice
and crunchy i'm not gonna fry
oh look at there
oh honey you see this middle one
oh
i just gotta walk away i'm sorry i just
had to walk awake i must say jade
yours looks real sweet why don't i taste
yours and you taste mine oh my god
[Music]
that's really good i like the toasted i
like the marshmallow you know i like the
fact that you took the basis of what i
gave you and you put a spin on it and
that means putting your own love into it
it's all about the love bo i love you i
love you too mom i just don't know how
to cook but i know how to put love into
food all right can i say my mom
something right with that egg
oh yes